obviously LeakyCon was amazing I'm just
talking right now a little bit so that I
can use some clips cuz I'm not gonna
make a whole clip video but good cuts
good so in 2007 I wrote a song about
Harry Potter that changed my life
and I made a promise to myself because
that was such a momentous occasion in my
life that I would write another song
about Harry Potter every year on the
anniversary of that video and I've done
that but this year I've saved my song so
that I could release it on the stage at
LeakyCon and now I've done that and so I
can release it to all of you if you
don't like acoustic cake or even singing
Hank then you could skip cuz there's
important stuff at the end of this video
there's a place where I always wanted to
go through a buttom at the station I
think you know it always seems to much
more beautiful than here but things are
not always quite how they appear cuz I
thought a little surging and become
concerned the twins erting world isn't
quite what we had learned so I'm gonna
share a few of those fears
this isn't love and mattered to the
widget of the UK cuz I barely got the
nerve to say the things I gotta say you
make it seem like your world is so
pristine when it angels versus demons
just on hard to pick a team well used to
wanna go out of Hogwarts do it now I got
a couple questions for you while you
don't seem to have much industry Wizards
work at schools or the Main Street and
by letting goblins house your currency
you're letting them control your whole
economy I don't understand how any
business gets done when wand only costs
seven galleons that doesn't seem like
much to me
letter to the Wizards of the UK cuz I'm
battling up the nerve and say the things
like it to say you make it seem like
you're Willis or Christine Weird Al's
versus demons it's done hard to pick a
team please don't want to go to Hogwarts
too but now I got a couple questions for
you they say you can put a stopper in
death well I'm wondering why you haven't
shared that yet cuz when my friends and
family died and the Wizards are on
helping well I wonder why you can make
no hands and regrow bones doctors 150
friggin years old and I don't think we'd
mind if you shared
and your isolationist tendencies a
worry me with a Dark Lord at your
doorstep you hadn't gone for help yet
you've got
is
taking your food yes lays baking your
food
I don't think it is
need a piece
the problems we've got he
which is why
that's open letter to the Whizzer than
you kid cuz I finally got the nerve to
say that think that I get a say you make
it seem like your world is so pristine
when it angels versus demons it's not
hard to pick a team let the woman go hot
woods do but now I got a couple
questions for you yeah I had a couple
questions for you and that's why I sang
you this
done there's another important date
coming up very soon did you may or may
not know about if you don't I can't
really talk about it cuz there's
somebody watching who we can't we got it
keep it on the DL there is a one time
only use mailing list that you can sign
up for and you need to do that by
Saturday night cuz that is when we was
sitting the email out if you want to
help with this thing it's not a lot of
work and I would really appreciate it
troop leader so that's all oh right I
forgot about about you I just it's a
llama elephant it's a puppy sized llama
elephant Who am I kidding it's Fred the
puppies aren't John I'll see you on
Tuesday
my voice is just so croaky
you